previously on super bunny man still dude
you were really luck on target please
let's dunk it it's mom your possible oh
all right you and me wait now Green Hill
Zone yeah all right yeah I got him you
get the ball you still die oh no this is
this changes everything
oh no no no I'm dribbling no one getting
through the ball is an ordeal no get him
get it in all you gotta do is get it in
there - - - Wow
that's how you win it all right in the
direction is a bit of a I didn't kill
you it was your own body score
[Applause]
don't worry I got this you don't got my
face interesting oh you can do this if
you hold it hold it I know I'm really
good right all right yep okay okay okay
oh I almost did it again listen to Wade
mostly do that okay wait I was dead it
wasn't my fault
I got it I got it I got it
[ __ ] wait it's all good so good right
now yeah that's how I do
no take it more kicking
hot don't kick me oh no go you're clear
you're clear some cop nice one Bob I got
it I got watch this way kick me I'm
trying
oh wait no oh
Tommy it's on me baby here we go oh [ __ ]
yes going domain you sexy color I've got
it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
okay Bob that was exactly what all of us
want to do I know [ __ ] incredible
here we go no no get over there the ice
is stopping me
[Applause]
I'm ready I'm ready for ball okay I'm
ready for ball I don't know if your help
you think you are I don't think helping
you much at all that was me that's me I
earned that I kicked that good [ __ ] Bob
I did that I think the most believable
dunk I've ever seen in my entire life
- save - I scored like eight baskets
yeah we got do you see I got it was
going
going our way at all I think Bob scored
all of your points no I do mostly Shawn
but okay teamwork
are we scoring on the wrong baskets wait
I was just told that mark and I won the
last match because we've been stored on
the wrong basket
we aren't raids we're defending red or
scoring on red oh wait no we we just
scored then we just score on the blue
green both have a point so where can we
right yeah we right I think I'm a
dolphin
the matter the same system of do that to
me okay take those me forget the rules
oh my god there was some dirty dancing
[ __ ] we I don't think so there we go
never never mind what nobody scores like
ice cores I defend I defend good Bob
that's some serious dunk game you got
ever feel like this is more of a 2v1
situation oh dear my fault no that's
cool all right there we go we're [ __ ]
gymnast Bob we're work we're doing so
we're doing some aerobatics that's what
they're called yeah aerobatic totally
intentional completely under presented
like on
[Applause]
you go away pop that out I popped it out
the wrong way so nice we know you won
well I mean I feel pretty good about
that one I think we all won what's the
last game mode stick pass the carrot
what does that mean gotta grab each
other's carrot wait now wait now wait
now wait I'll be I'm pretty good I think
we can all right where are we getting it
in basket for the wrong team there again
broke my neck okay
and I mean Oh God we saw this is
horrible this games hard enough as it is
it's fine it's just about finding your
goal does that count
wait wait what the help can you steal I
got one out of your thing apparently
they said it was to ever has the most of
their baskets by the end
oh I'm the neck destroyer
oh there's one up here yes wait yes [ __ ]
I'm gonna try not to mess this up that's
great okay get away from the C key wait
okay God ow
don't Bob get away from I'll steal yours
I'll steal yours did you see this come
on mark bring it over here I bet you
can't do it in 11 seconds I bet you
you're frying you get out you're gonna
paint away from me
oh hey Mark how's it going I'm staying
here you guys can do steal ours while we
you killed each other either Mike her
out get away from a cart you stinky yeah
you a bum get out of here
not break your neck how do marks great
great great it's great how's your carrot
that's going beep pretty good well we
have two and you have zero you do know
someone okay well we want to show
everyone that we won we won for moans
handsome team of the Year award goes to
us yeah that's only a subcategory though
so it doesn't really count
it's a way no a wins away it's an honor
to be nominated alone but you know you
weren't nominated so I'm so hot and
bothered and sweaty right now I don't
need to know the details wait I turned
all I need to know is that when you play
on my team you dial your gamer skill
down to the bottom of the barrel and
then when you're going against me it's
like I've got the mechanics perfectly
here I was cheering him on the whole
time watching us the whole time and
there's a difference that's nicely done
you shouldn't have to punch down to rise
up I'm here oh you're gonna pop your I'm
hanging up on Bob with you yeah yeah
yeah yeah get a goal Bob I mean just
ganging up on me doesn't really work cuz
I don't fight back so you're saying we
win yeah we would ha that's right no but
nothing
whoo take that your team really
undermining my strategies here with
[Music]
you